Europe is facing a major refugee crisis
and many many refugees are stranded and
angry try desperately trying to come
here many have arrived already what's
the political situation right now in
Europe I think Europe is in a crisis the
European Union is in a deep crisis all
the member states are in the crisis
because i do not see a real european
responsibility i see that national
States try to get rid of this challenge
and this is absolutely unacceptable
everyday Europe is dying what needs to
happen on the European scale to change
this we need a shared responsibility I'm
really happy that Germany is receiving
so many refugees that Sweden his top of
the countries who are receiving refugees
that that Austria is receiving refugees
but what's going on in hungary on
Bulgaria building Francis 175 kilometers
or in Bulgaria a wall with 100 kilometer
or treating refugees like we see the
pictures from Budapest is unacceptable
so if Europe is not ready to receive or
two to face this challenge as a common
European challenge then also the idea of
Europe will collapse now Germany is
receiving many refugees in fact some
3,000 have arrived according to police
numbers how well is Germany equipped for
this massive influx of refugees arriving
here I think we were not really prepared
we saw and the numbers one side ok
perhaps this year there will be two
hundred thousand this was not a very
good strategy I think it's better to be
really open to prepare the people in
Germany that we have to receive many
people and that there will be more
coming and that we are able to do it and
what I see in Munich in these days it is
it really a wonderful example of
humanitarian responsibility and this is
a Germany our president is speaking this
is a bright Germany this is a Germany of
people who shall we have hearts not of
stone